I was able to hit the third bll the
third bll was like the most aggressive
it was so aggressive that was as it was
chasing people um when people would try
to jump out of the ring it would try to
jump after them and it would like
halfway get out hit the fence fall over
onto its back into the ring again be
dazzled for a second and that's when I
was like oh this is my motherucker do
you have good luck after that you think
you think that helped I never felt so
removed from everything I had known in
life you know I'm very inspired after
this I'm going to go kick a
cat why would you do same same dude same
same he's like they said this is good
[Music]
luck welcome back to another amazing
episode of the careful boys where today
we have Mr Giani in the building power
[__] like
that like the clap uh so we got a
question here's a prompt what is
something that you've done that you
recommend everyone do before they die
dude oh my God that's so crazy I just
got back from Europe literally I said
this to my mom I went to this place
called Dingle Ireland it's a [__]
weird place whatever it is the most
beautiful scenery I've ever seen in my
life green everywhere huh dude it was
insane Dingle d i n g l e what does it
look like like Game of Thrones
Landscapes exactly Auto wants to finish
dingleberry for sure it is beautiful go
to Dingle I know I wish I had something
better to say but just go to Dingle my
guy you know what I mean what you do in
Dingle um I I went on a world tour to a
bunch of different European countries
and I met a girl in every city that I
went did did you go with your friend no
I didn't I didn't go with with with I
feel like that's the thing everyone
should do before they die every [__]
country and meet a girl that was almost
the annoying part I was like let me
enjoy the scenery okay I don't care that
you need french fries right now okay um
but yeah it it um it was beautiful so
you think you said you're saying
everyone should go there everyone has to
go there I said this I was like Mom you
have to like everyone should go to this
place before they die so besides the
scenery what else did you do while
you're in Dingle eat potato yeah a lot
of potato a lot of fish and cuz there's
a lot of it's like near the water so
it's a lot of like seafood yeah what's
the best thing you had in in Europe or
in Ireland Dingle let's just talk about
Dingle the fish and chips were insane oh
insane insane fish and chips that's got
to be [__] insane yeah you drink at
all I did I drink a little bit because I
when I went to Poland like they drink so
much vodka there so I was drinking like
wine and vodka in Poland wait what was
the world tour that you're on I don't
know I just I we're on strike right now
and I was like I'm just sitting oh it
was gian's World Tour I thought he was
like I thought it was like you were you
were doing some [__] no just went on my
own my own little world tour holy how
long was your European World Tour for
it's about a month yeah that's a good
time yeah that sounds and D what was the
best experience out of the the whole
month I mean in different places I had
great experiences but like all like your
memory was like wow my memory was like
wow this is is an amazing place to be
I'm going to remember that it's a good
name to remember what was the question
again I just think about Dingle now what
do you know about Dingle IR what's
something that you've done that you
recommend everyone I said that I said
Dingle so just send me the 5K to my
account it's it's Ireland tourism on the
phone right now Irish
tourism recommend everyone do before
they die yeah something that you've done
honestly I thought J you was going to
have or see your [__] it's that it's
Dingle or look at your [__] I'd
rather go to Dingle they're both kind of
in the same
category traveling is probably one of
the best things though cuz it's like
give a specific where where spefic we
got Dingle over here I'm sure you got a
specific place you got to choose one I
would say feudal Japan yep knew it I
would say go somewhere that is like
almost the opposite of where what you're
used to so for
example Vietnam was crazy for me because
but you grew up in s bro
Valley littleon got you there no you
know what it is is because I've traveled
the world a lot but I've never been I've
never been to a country that doesn't
cater to Americans yeah so it feels like
that sounds like
[__] I don't want to go
there it feel it's like communist land
like you go around and they cater to
Russians and like French would be like
the most western so they'll speak French
before they speak English so then but
then you see everywhere it's like
communist stars and [__] and all their
tourists are like Chinese and Russians
and then you're just sitting there like
I don't matter as an American like
everything is just for everybody else
but then I didn't realized that until I
went there cuz everywhere else it's like
the tourist area there's something
that's English speaking or there there's
a lot of American tourists so you don't
really feel like you're I tell you what
you got that US Passport you matter to
the women there yeah
I probably why what did you do how how
did you take advantage of that I didn't
take advantage of
it chaos strikes again see what you do
you see the [__] you cause out here B
let him finish the story you're a
passport brother yeah yeah they see you
guys see me in Vietnam I'm wearing a
Putin shirt M let's
go W with the
flag I think the difference is just when
you go all over and you're like at a
result or whatever right you don't
really feel like you're away from
America right that's what I realized
until you go to places where they just
don't know what an American is and
you're just like what the [__] now I
really feel like I'm far but yeah that's
why I always get a Airbnb where I go
because I want to live like um there
rather the hotel right right I I mean I
did get the noble hotel in Spain
so that was like the one thing that I
was like okay fine I'll just get a hotel
here um but everywhere else I went
I everywhere so stupid every else I went
I got an
airbn I want to stay with the locals in
Vietnam and I was at the Sheron
dude bro no lie I got like a penous
suite for like less than 200 bucks like
a two room like I was like what the [__]
it's cheap there though it's so cheap
but like you're getting us brand yeah
was like what I will say London blows
because it's like one it's like one it's
more expensive bro it is it's like the
pound is like 1.5 I was like everything
was I was like this that's way better
than you it used to be like 2 to one
like 10 years ago [__] that dude and in
the rooms are smaller and the beds are
all like twin size and you're like what
the [__] and their teeth are messed up
yep you telling me you didn't like
riding the double decker buses dude did
you get to the tour buses I did that in
when I went to think
no I did
doic around the London egg dude I did do
it one time I was like e [__] get
away just
kidding when you when you went to Europe
were you like ah the motherland and then
you walked around and you're like my
peoples no it's weird because I dude I
was in Venice Italy and I was walking
around I was like I don't [__] relate
to any of these [__] and I'm
100% Italian my name is Giani Vincent
Paulo I was like get away from me dude
you know I mean I was like yeah I I just
feel like I don't relate to like what
lower middle class no no
no no but like I don't like you know
when people go home they're like like
these are my people like I don't feel
like that when I go to Italy I'm like
where's maliboo you know what I mean I'm
like what the [__] am I doing here feel
I don't even know if I feel that
anywhere probably sgv nah a lot more
dumb I see him at the barber shop man
you're the same way you were Senor year
wait what's what's that the valley oh oh
like a lot of people they don't leave
this bubble right so I'll talk to them
and I'm like you're like 43 now but you
still sound like the 17-year-old That I
Used to Know You know so probably like
just the gym for you yeah bar not really
really we this is a better question
actually do you let's go back die
something something before you die you
answer I've been thinking something that
you done that you got to recommend
everybody to do before they die I think
you should get in a fight at least once
in your life I agree but what if you die
never been in a fight well at least you
did it then you die yeah yeah yeah yeah
you got it do you could think uh a
street fight or like a sanctioned F yeah
like a street fight or do you count hard
sparring in a gym count that I'll say
it's probably safer to do it in a gym so
I would say you count hard sparring as a
real F but maybe both maybe both I feel
like it's too controlled though cuz you
don't know about yourself until you like
that's true you don't but then when you
ramp it up and the like sometimes in
sparring like in a gym you make the
condition where it's like a real [__]
fight so then it becomes automatically
like oh [__] your heart starts beating
you start to feel a little stress and
then but you doarn the most about who
you are yeah for sure for sure and you I
think it's good to just push back on
stuff I got to ask you a professional
fighter guy I got to ask you a question
okay uh check this out I jumped people
and I got jumped a lot cuz that was the
thing you did you didn't you you don't
really do one on on that much yeah yeah
does that count I think that's more
hardcore you've lived not as a what is
it like a you start at 11 years old to
like what high school I think uh every
five years you should get in a [__]
SC dud you're like [__] it's coming up
who's the first guy I see at Bristol
Farms yeah I'm kick his [__] ass but
I think people that do do kind of get in
fights or have been punched in the face
just tend to be cooler people overall I
do agree but they have to do this before
college and then it gets too dangerous
and it becomes criminal yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're right you're right you're
right but that's why you know you doing
gym you just sign up to a place and get
in a little bit of a fight you'll be
fine today's video is brought to you by
Lumi do your armpits smell like [__]
nah but it smells like [__] or do your
[__] smell like armpits M that's a good
question cuz what's dope about Lumi is
they made full body deodorant the reason
why Bart brought up [__] is because
it's made from a [__]
doctor so you know it works very good on
your body you could use this on your
whole entire body not just your stinky
little armpits or your leg pits or your
butt pits it's for everything yeah it's
pH Balan yep no parabens no aluminum
designed by OBGYN like we said mhm and
it smells really good this one is the
whole body deodorant this is my favorite
one it's clean Tangerine you know what I
mean oh man I could just if you had this
all over
your We're not gonna go there but you
know what I'm thinking about what are
you thinking about if you had it all
over I'd be all up in that oh as a
special offer for listeners new
customers get $5 off a Lumi starter pack
with the code OTR at Lumi deodorant.com
that equates to $40 off a Lumi starter
pack when you go to lumid deodorant.com
and use code OTR thank you Lumi for
making this holiday season smell a whole
much better this one's cool cucumber
it's pH optimized so you could have it
in between your batwing balls oh I need
my balls to smell better if you get
suplex when you're 13 years old it's
okay but when you're 25 you're going to
break something yeah you might die you
know oh dude I have a good fight story
what I um while we were speaking about
Russians um I uh so when I was younger I
was crazy when I was younger like I was
like I I was actually I yeah that's
actually very fair um I played hockey
and I was i f you're scrapping all the D
I was a scrappy [__] Russians
are good at everything especially hockey
too huh bro there was this Russian team
and they have like six or seven guys
that are like big NHL players now on
this team and they would come in they
would fly in from Russia and they would
this summer tournament they would come
in and play us all the time so we played
this team they like smoked us and after
the game I was like walking out of the
locker room and I was like fighting
everyone on the ice I was maybe like 12
and I was like hitting kids quick
question I never understood in hockey
like under what conditions can two
people just grab each other and start
socking each other face at 12 years old
at 12 years old you have helmets and
gloves on you're just like there's not
legal fighting but like in junior hockey
you're allowed to drop the gloves and
fight into five minute penalty but what
is that what's that it's honestly like
better for the game because if like say
for example someone is out like taking
cheap shots at people you could actually
injure someone but if there's fighting
no one's going to I'm not going to take
a cheap shot on you cuz their big
[__] is going to come beat the
[__] out of me that's cool so it's like
yeah it's more of like uh you know
everyone you know right it keeps the
game in line that's my two tents on it
people are like oh it's like well you so
basically when the aggressiveness or
cheap shots escalate to a point where
it's like all right let's [__] throw
down right now and then everybody just
clears the floor and the refs like here
we go that's it or or your team's
getting smoked and you got to like fire
them up and someone just like [__] so
if if there was an equivalent if wasn't
equivalent in basketball would it be
like if someone fouled then everyone
moves away and the two people they just
scrap like flagrant though not like a
regularl flagrant too you get to you get
to scrap James Harden every time yeah so
basically I was leaving the locker room
and then one of the Russian kids said
something to me when I was leaving it
was like five of them outside the locker
room and I was alone and for I was crazy
as kid I just cracked one of these kids
in the face and like six Russian kids
are on top of me like stomping me out it
was literally it was like I was like 12
years old and I like left yeah I
literally left the thing I was like you
Russian [__] dude like I'm like
bleeding everywhere I'm like these
communist F I was like but yeah call
them commies were they r i was 12 dude I
wouldn't say that
now I mean back then you probably would
have been right right that was the
Soviet Union back then so I don't know
dude how [__] old do you think I
am I still play high school on
television
okay what about you Colleen um I I kind
of said it yesterday okay I feel like
you should do something you're afraid of
so like for me it was Heights so I went
skydiving so find your fear and and do
that un more
examples yeah you should do that dude go
to prison
[__] you won you [__] I'm afraid I'm
afraid of jail go to jail y I was going
to say within a certain scope of non
stupidity all right all right all right
wait how do you guys how does everyone
think they would do in jail oh not great
probably not good bro not great I think
you'd Fair pretty well oh don't know
you're a good fighter yeah but you know
all it takes is like bro I got beautiful
hair I'm going to get boned every day
this is true I got to go bald before I
go in yeah that's a more important
question who's going to get boned most
I'll do horrible in jail you think so
dude I look I used to work in West
Hollywood I'll I probably be me me yeah
you get a bet though yeah I think I'm
only going to walk
backwards hey my butt cheeks are always
like no this is the time that actually
sees his ass no Everywhere I Go
Everywhere I Go I'm looking at people
cuz I want I don't ever want to
[__] you want to Temp them they're
all like holding him down open his
[__] he's like what's it look
like they're like actually not that bad
it's pretty good Anthony Lee is for sure
going to get bones why you got to point
when you look how pretty you are dude i'
I'd take a ride myself if I
could that's why I'm going to stand next
to him all day just to make sure the
prettier yeah this is the pretty table
dude you guys will get bumed in a
heartbeat look at his beautiful hair
don't you feel that's something you you
could grab that there's like physical
like interaction with there's an
interactive experience and then I
started to squat so my butt is kind of
bubbly so but I feel like Yeah Yeah Joe
got a little bubble but I feel like Joe
would just be a a w he he would adapt to
being a wild boy and just and just
scaring every I would accept the fact
that a lot of dudes are going to want to
[__] me so I would use that to my
advantage as currency I would be the
girlfriend to the [__] toughest guy
in there be the second in command you
know what I mean so I got to utilize
what I got yeah yeah some people are
like no tough guy it's like well be a
tough guy on the bottom as a pawn I'll
be the queen of the jail you know what I
mean I'll be eating my [__] Top Ramen
smoking cigarettes like I'm living baby
bottom Ramen bottom Ramen but joke got
Kingpin Vibes bro like if you're the
toughest guys if you're the toughest
guy's girlfriend and he asks you what do
you want to eat do are you still
indecisive I don't know whatever you
want like whatever's a commentary I
don't know see wait but what if you guys
what if I go to the same prison and he
break he sees me go he's cute um what if
he breaks up with you then now you're on
the and we're fighting
bro made the best Queen win I am not
leaving my nice luxury life he's
mine I climbed up this ring
there you know how many ass I had to get
my [__] you got to go up the ladder with
it you can't get straight to the top guy
no you got to you got to prove your
worth you got to you got to start rumors
that's the key dude everyone's trying to
be a tough guy I'm like seduced a tough
guy isn't that mainly an American thing
just like but [__] yeah just getting
rammed in prison I don't know you think
they do that in Norwegian prisons I feel
like it's a predominant maybe it's just
a human thing have you guys seen Locked
Up Abroad there used to be a whole show
about like Americans getting in trouble
in other countries and their stories and
[__] do they but [__] out there they
probably will but [__] Americans no
there's a Netflix show uh actually the
new season just came out I watch it all
the time it's called Lock Up Abroad no
it's it's called um uh world's toughest
prisons oh older show yeah no but a new
episode literally just came out like a
couple days ago I actually watched it
they don't talk about the [__] um
unfortunately not cuz I was curious
about that too but um we all are he
wants to know which one to go to where
is the [__] I'm like I'm like about
45 minutes into this episode I don't
care about the [__] Cuisine okay get
to the good [__] is that what they talk
about on the show yeah someone sees his
title and it's like oh what should I do
as a bucket list and you go on and it's
like oh I'm going to get [__] in prin
oh sounds pretty cool that's on Joe's
algorithm yeah it's like well um going
back to the topic I think uh traveling
would be what traveling to prisons
abroad traveling to prison going to
prison in Dingle
Ireland what do you what do you think I
feel like you're a worldly person this
guy travels a lot don't you think he
looks like he travels a lot dude I'm not
going to say anybody looks like anything
I'm just going to be here this guy's
good we're trying to trap him yo yeah he
looks like he goes to Tokyo a lot like
dude I'm gonna [__] dude I'm a prison
princess right
um I've talked about on here before but
I think one of the most eye openening
experiences with Gran was also had a
young time was when I was traveling I
and I went running with the bulls in
Spain I feel like super diving into like
the culture of another entire different
nation and culture like really
submitting yourself to like not just
like visiting and like having a tourist
perspective but like experiencing and
engaging going to the noou yeah that sh
yeah
noou yeah say that the noou but we saw
him the running with the bulls from my
penous site I was like but that [__]
really like brought me to the ground
level of like what they do and why they
do it even if it didn't make sense you
had to just ask questions when you're
getting like a pamphlet that says like
be careful cuz you might die like stuff
like that makes you feel like you're
really a part of something else and when
it's so different that when you go home
home feels different you know what I
mean I think doing something like that
that's why I want to like go out to like
the what's called elom or what the giant
tomato fight there that's why I want to
go to like the holy Festival in India U
with all like the colorful [__] dust
and stuff like I want to just try things
that are like super deep about those
other nations and cultures because
that's the only way you might really
like learn more about yourself do have
people died in the running with the
bulls oh dude all the time I want say
all the time but I feel like there's one
every year dude there's always a video
on [__] Instagram like check out this
guy who got gored by a bull cuz dude
it's it it is very Loosey Goosey it
seems like it seems like it's I feel
like the people are more [__] uh
dangerous than the Bulls because like if
you try to like run to the side while
you're running on the Cobblestone
they'll push you back in you know what I
mean and that like the running with the
bulls is only half of it like after you
run with the bulls you have a decision
to go into the stadium or not and if you
go into the stadium that's like part two
and and part two is where they put out
they let out young Bulls one at a time
with the corks on their horns but the
corks Never Last for more than like 30
seconds and it's good luck for the year
if you can like slap the bull either
with your hand or with the newspaper
yeah I'm out really get that close yeah
so it's just running around in this ring
and everybody's [__] cheering for you
and [__] like that and obviously if you
can like wrestle the B the longer you
hold on to it the louder the Roar of the
of the crowd so it's like the most
[__] adrenaline did you do that part
yeah I did you wrestled did you smack
the with the newspaper I was able to hit
the third bll the third bll was like the
most aggressive it was so aggressive
that as it was chasing people um when
people would try to jump out of the ring
it would try to jump after them and it
would like halfway get out hit the fence
fall over onto its back into the ring
again be dazzled for a second and that's
when I was like oh this is my
[__] so once it started chasing
somebody else I started running after it
and when it [__] tried to jump over
and fell down I got up to it while it
was like lying down I SLA the [__] out
of it like three times people were hella
yeah and I I jumped out you have good
luck after that you think you think that
helped I'm still alive so I feel like
I'm pretty solid how drunk were you not
drunk at all cuz that [__] is crazy your
Your Heart Is For Real being you have to
get there like 5: in the morning too
when the bowl Falls does the ground
shake no it's not like that I mean it's
it's still earth like it's [__] 2,000
lb hey we got to ask
dude
but but it was definitely like I never
felt so removed from everything I had
known in like you know I'm very inspired
after this I'm going to go kick a
cat why would you do same same dude same
same he's like they said this is good
[Laughter]
[Music]
luck